et maintenant les messieurs dans l'union
on ne touche pas
solution bassiste essentiellement co qui
met le tout à l'envers
non merci je vais adresser votre ou bien
vous pensez à quoi en ce moment à la
question vous allez me poser le matin
quand vous vous regardez dans le miroir
vous pensez à quoi
ça dépend des matins ouais ce matin non
juste coupé les cheveux hier je disais
quelques attaques mais non non ah bon ça
va oui vous auriez aimé ressembler à qui
que vous étiez petit thierry la fronde
thierry la fronde quand on vous demande
un autographe vous marquez quoi c'est
parti pour l'argent je fais un dessin
avec un sourire quand avez vous pleuré
pour la dernière fois il y a quatre
jours à madagascar devant des enfants
devant une des enfants devant le public
devant devant le pays devant comment ce
qui s'y passe devant ce qui est à la
fois merveilleux et à la fois déroutant
parfois écran vous changeriez quoi on
vous si vous aviez une baguette magique
la susceptibilité ouais elle encombre
en vieillissant ne s'arrange pas faux
contrairement à bon nombre n'a plus de
aussi n'a plus peut-être plus d'humour
plus de recul puis distance mais mais
pas moins de sensibilité donc ça que
pourriez-vous dire de plus négatif sur
vous c'est un peu casse cou et un moment
je fais un peu trop jouer les jeux trop
en faire je préfère ma foi je je je suis
boulimique boulimique et je sais pas
pour continuer ça nous fait du bien pas
pour combler convaincu et tout ça est
valide c'est qu'elle sic analyse de
lutte
quelle insulte qui vous a fait le plus
mal sale juif qui avez vous le plus
envie d'épater ma famille mes frères ma
mère qui est la dernière chose que vous
faites le soir avant de vous coucher
c'est à la télé oui quel est le surnom
qu'on vous donne que vous haïssez non la
chose que je hais c'est le patrick avec
plusieurs hits tels risques
avez vous une meilleure opinion de vous
qu'à 20 ans non je me trouve mieux qu'à
30 ans ouais mais ne pas mieux qu'à 20
ans d'accord de quelle question aimeriez
vous avoir la réponse
après la mort
je suis pas saper la marasme quel est le
mot que vous ne supportez pas d'entendre
boy souvent pourquoi je pense qu'à
chaque fois qu'il ait prononcé il
fabrique un antisémite dans le jura est
celui qui l'entend force un mot qu'on
devrait rayer de notre vocabulaire
surtout à l'intérieur de la communauté
quelle doctrine ou idéologie vous fait
bander les de logis marxiste si elle
avait été un ciel a été un succès mais
il était vraiment dans cette bande et
c'est pas le mot mois ces doctrines qui
n'est pas le mot voilà patrick boulet
lauriane s'efface série
femina